hello youtube this is the reuben report
i'm dave rubin this is michelle collins
this is michael ausiello that's Gloria
Bigelow and we got to get right to it
Barack Obama the president of the United
States he did something that as a sci-fi
guy I just cannot believe talking
sequester and he confused a Star Trek
reference with the star wars reference
let's watch the clip I know that this
has been some of the conventional wisdom
that's been floating around Washington
that somehow even though most people
agree that I'm being reasonable that
most people agree I'm presenting a fair
deal the fact that they don't take it
means that I should somehow you know do
a Jedi mind-meld with these folks and
convince them to do what's right yeah it
never gets easy I'd never get these
watching that clip a Jedi mind-meld
there's no such thing it's a Jedi mind
trick and a Vulcan mind meld Michelle I
know you are very upset about I actually
love it it's almost like the hummus
sampler of a sci-fi like for someone
like me who really knows not that much
about it I feel like I would take a
little sampling I can see the hatred
literally shooting out of Michael's eyes
and I initiate it had no idea what
you're even talking no I mean mind trick
mind meld mindless I don't like it why
are you not a sci-fi no I don't know I
have no I didn't even catch I still
don't even know what you're talking
about are we sure wasn't an intentional
thing like you know my my niece and
nephew tell me that mashups are all the
craze right now the is impossible that's
what he was doing it I have never heard
a young person sound older than the way
you said my niece and nephew with the
mashups and they're backwards hats and
all that stuff it was a sci-fi I'm gonna
go with that I agree with you I by
sci-fi mashup what wasn't there like a
moment in that where he's sort of
stammering through it as if he knew that
the mistake was coming and we've all
done this when you're talking and the
next thing you know you make a mistake
but there's just nothing
like we got to give him a break sometime
like so he you know so you mix them up a
Vulcan mind-meld zordon is a Jedi
mind-meld yeah it sounds a little bit
vaudevillian like I like the sound of
that I think it's catchy and I think if
someone were smart they'd catch on to it
that's what make a thing out of it yeah
yeah let's do that when he took the
focus away from the sequester so again
maybe this was intentional right he knew
the reaction it was gonna get and that's
actually what I think is most
interesting about this because nobody
knew what the sequester was but you know
all the pundits new and all the nice
people you can be Smith again that's
file anyone crew action that's gonna go
over they can edit that i'm ninety-nine
my 55 years old come on remember that
even over my basic where nobody talked
about michelle take it away can you
explain that oh I'd really rather not we
have to explain it you know it's like
sequestering ettore it doesn't make any
sense I've done no preparation for this
no idea what a thing it's totally fine
alright so people don't know what the
sequester is but then this type of thing
happens any trends on Twitter everyone
goes completely bonkers have we reached
a point in like the discussion in
America where the little errors and the
the sci-fi references are more important
than what's actually going on absolutely
I mean I think it's always I mean the
question aren't the Pope's being so
close like isn't there a sequester
happening there too are those guys being
sequestration's efficiently but that's
the problem is they're not being so
sensitive enough except that George be
honest I'm questioning now to to like
come to some kind of decisions well
they're supposed to only be allowed to
molest X amount of kids or something
they're trying to come up with the
number that they're all comfortable in
yeah a lot of them want it to be a lot
higher so you sequester than it is
Michael what do you think about that
you're you're a big tweeter and a
Twitter person le what do you think of
these things that like gay you know they
get their own life well after hearing
what the sequester was all about I found
the whole Star Wars versus Star Trek
thing much more interesting yeah like
that is it that's it that's a topic that
I can really get into ya dig deep into
the sequester thing I don't care does
it's like Li disgraces the Beatles a
little bit like that big a little bit so
letting Iran also i just like to watch
nerds fight yeah it's fun the new i go
to comic-con and watch them get online
it's like no I was here no I was here
another seats
mine that's fun yeah now after all this
do you all know the difference between a
Jedi mind trick Oh God we're gonna be
kind of okay fine I still not is no idea
its i still take it away stalking but if
I and I could be wrong I will be uh the
Jedi mind trick is when you use reminds
like lift things or like to manipulate
someone's thought ah ok yeah we're Oh
relax I me help and then the Vulcan mind
trick my smell my mouth you're pulling
it over oh well I guess when you do this
with the neck from like spaceballs
that's what I thought that was well that
I like did this event you faint would
equalize also from Star Trek man Jubilee
what's up that's just like a bulk in
mattapan did the Vulcan pinch I don't
know what uh one of mine Waldo's I'm
sorry all right well clearly we didn't
resolve anything bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Ruben report
enter code Ruben report for twenty
percent off your next purchase